Generally, like what to say?
Who else is there? Karpagam Sarikka has left.
Subramaniam is not here, Karthikeyan is not here. Okay, I will record this for you only and tell you.
Recording has started, anna.
Good.
Actually, like, what is it? If we put it in actions.json, it will only record the actions it performs. Okay.
It should actually have been in events.json. Why should it have been in events.json?
Actually, first I opened the app. What to say?
I opened the app. If I said I opened the app, that's an event.
An event is generally going to be in the past tense. Okay. The app opened, that's an event.
Okay.
15 seconds passed. What to say about the app? 15 seconds passed since the app opened. I couldn't interact. It's loading. That's an event.
Okay. It crashed. That's an event. None of these are actions it performs.
The actions it performs can be recorded as an event.
If I say I did this, I did that, I did this, then it can be recorded as an event.
That is, like what to say? I picked it 50/50. That's an event.
It's not just what it does. If the game shows a pop-up, that can also be made into an event.
So, if this is recorded in events.json, then actions.json is not good enough.
Okay. Why am I telling you this now?
As I told you, surf surf means this was prepared after three or four hours of discussion.
But even then, I didn't have the idea to record those events. It's only coming now.
So, what is this? Whoever designs it will evolve gradually. That's not the point. But we need to know what we are doing. Otherwise, a design cannot be made.
Why did I say it should be in events.json?
What's its name? Like, JSON is generally useful when there is a very large volume of data.
Generally, if you look at a normal JSON, there will be at least 10,000 records, at least 10,000 lines.
That's why it shouldn't be committed. That's the reason why JSON shouldn't be committed. That's the reason.
Even if it's committed, it must be in the DB.
Okay. Next, they said that MD is created, JSON is created, right?
JSON will have a high volume. If you create MD to the same extent, it's of no use.
So, in MD, there will only be some of what comes in events.json.
That is, I opened the app.
If I say the app has loaded, a screenshot can be taken for that.
That is, only selected events should come to MD.
The screen changed. Something happened. That is, if you want to clear a board, let's say.
If there are 10 moves to clear that board, taking screenshots of all 10 moves is not that. It's madness.
Okay. Actually, what we can do is, the initial screenshot of the board comes, right? And that,
The one that comes before clearing it last, right? Taking one screenshot of that is enough.
For one level.
We don't have time to do it for 10 levels.
Then, sorry, we don't have time to do it for 10 boards.
So, like, this is where the exception comes, if it's a bug report, let's say. That needs to be done.
So, actually, like,
Two things. That is, only important things should be recorded. And also when the state changes.
A new level has loaded. I went to the settings screen.
Okay. The context changes, right? It should know to record at that point. If it's like that,
That thing, right? Like, what is this? It can be actions.md. Or what to say?
It can even be flow.md.
That is, what does flow mean? I did this first, I did this second. That is, it could even be how the test flow went.
Now this is being recorded, right? After this is recorded,
The actual findings, right?
In findings, this place can be linked. The MD file can be linked. Findings is an MD file.
Findings should be MD.
Why should findings be MD?
The very reason for recording those findings is that it's going to tell a human. Look at all these, and so on.
Bugs can also be recorded in that finding.
After looking at that finding file, if it's a bug in the finding, what to say? We will say it should be treated as a bug.
Or if it's not a bug, then it will write it down in knowledge. This is actually not a bug, and so on.
That knowledge, knowledge can be an MD file. No problem.
Knowledge will not be much anyway.
Consider knowledge as a folder, basically. Keep knowledge as a folder.
It doesn't even have to be a file.
Okay. Inside that folder, however it saves the knowledge, let it save. That knowledge should be in context.
Now what's the matter?
In this, what to say?
All MD files can be committed.
Okay.
Even more, they should be done. Because it's not going to be large. The size is not going to be large.
Nothing in JSON should be committed.
Okay.
If you keep it in the DB only if it's committed, there's no problem. There's no point in keeping it in the DB.
If they start with events.json,
And they actually run it for one hour daily, let's say.
It will prepare a 100 GB file daily.
In 10 days, all the space on the hard disk will be gone.
Okay.
So, it's better to just overwrite this.
What?
Like, that some temporary JSON.
When logging findings, what to say? It's better to log under that run ID, by putting the run ID. In MD.
Okay, anna.
Or for each run, have separate JSON files inside that folder,
And then if it's not committed when needed, it's only going to be on that machine. It's not going to other machines.
So, JSON should not be committed. JSON should not be committed. But like,
I don't even know about actions.
Okay. The reason is,
Depending on the file size. Many actions will come. It doesn't mean they should be committed. Large ones will be created daily.
So, findings.md, right? I don't even know if that should be committed.
But two
Issues are there, right?
Issues and knowledge, definitely issues and bugs and knowledge must be committed.
Okay, anna, okay, anna.
Because next time, that is, they have finished testing. If you are going to take that test report and work on it,
Then the agent should have that knowledge.
It won't work without committing it.
Okay, anna.
Soumya akka, you should have had all this understanding yesterday.
It's all in the document.
Actually, what happened, Soumya akka. That is, we can't read much, that's why we
I stopped the meeting recording.
Good, akka.
Soumya akka,